that's Cobra my name is Barbra and
welcome to Huntsman they are Fitch so
I'm in the middle of nowhere okay or
flood road has the orphanage all right
all fish everywhere else good job lot
why would you call him when I'm not to
here I suspect a trap don't worry I
played enough horror games to know where
this is going gonna be jab love will do
a hug huh what okay
it's been fun talking to you guys I'm
gonna get the [ __ ] out of there thank
you so how am I still hearing you stupid
stupid phone I'm not gonna help you I
hate phones why am i holding this then
okay yep that guy was drunk whatever
drove that [ __ ] oh let's go in the field
like that's not creepy at all great idea
pits
yeah I'm sure nothing bad will happen
now hello
ha I know I drank too much and I got
lost I guess but [ __ ] mine I don't know
is he gonna be this creepy ah gosh okay
we're fine that's kind of it's not gonna
be okay this time
Oh God could you move a little slower
please that'd be great oh there we go oh
my god I'm a genius
shut shut now that's too creepy I all
keep going here alright hello all this
guy's that clown looks like a potato
final last words that cloud looks like a
potato oh here we go
this looks like a party alright hi Trey
cool good to see you too Trey are you
creepy tree man you creepy alright then
what do we got here more objects bloke
nanion a miss the ex is short
Mimmi move your hand miss list I chopped
it off Matt I will know you won't shut
up oh yes I will
shut up both of you hello Adam and Kari
at least I [ __ ] it's quiet now get me
my flowers there are mine flowers mine
flowers right ahead flowers I have
flowers what they went through my hand
nice nice
all right well as a great man once said
life is life
Anna and Anna okay what now I'm lost
again god damn it
all right let's go inside Oh God
God you're louder than your ass goddamn
except it's not a frog what did someone
say something frog did you say that frog
let me pick you up frog oh man you're my
best friend frog oh you're so cute
I'll put you in my pants through my hand
thanks frog appreciate it all right
let's go up and party I'm sure nothing
bad will happen up here right frog don't
spook me don't spook me yeah that's
right we dodged that spook like a boss
Oh going down froggy froggy what are you
doing there
froggy you crazy you're coming with me
you son of a [ __ ] froggy froggy I'm
serious you may be swagalicious but
you're not living with that pain thank
you that's right froggy you and I are
best friends
why don't know why you do that thing
through my hand it's kind of creepy hell
yeah how weird that door may the exact
same noise as the other well hello
I have your frog I don't even know I'm
supposed to help a [ __ ] set it
it's supposed to help them hello what
what one room of work okay cool okay
this is actually kind of creepy I don't
know what opened door ha ha ha ha
that's how you open doors just [ __ ]
smack your hand in front of it that
always works kind of don't know what I'm
supposed to do but that's okay
jab not also did what shut up shut you
don't know me [ __ ] uhh I just don't
know where to go
oh yes yes of course shut up
[ __ ] attention [ __ ] okay yes up up
we go
nope up we're not going up we're not
going we're not going up yeah what's
doing that hello shut up shut up shut up
cess what the hell alright it's a party
it's a party it's gonna be fine it's
gonna be fine this place is not a big
deal often nope
you're what that's a that's a weird name
for a Dilla
alright you may think we're [ __ ] I say
yes you say no hey say bah no no huh
Yosh a goodbye and I say hello yes
there's her peepee alcohol let's get
drunk and [ __ ] him I mean I know he's
ugly but a man's gotta do what a man's
gotta do you know
yeah that looks light looks about right
that's how we drink our bottles in
Sweden with Fitz them with our hand Oh a
ball how nice Hey Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] we are
more dead than a butt that has been
sitting for a really long time and lost
all its blood and then it fills up what
pretty for I know I'm beautiful but shut
up oh your ribbons dude just [ __ ] off I
don't have time for you alright
her ribbons ah there's the key oh my god
whoa wow wow wow wow wow
would you like a massage mr. potato too
bad you ain't getting one I'll come back
for you later [ __ ]
okay all right I deserved a massage
after all this [ __ ] uh-oh we all knock
no don't tell me this [ __ ] goes down
okay we're doing this together it's
gotta be fine it's gotta be fine going
down or up in horror movies games
whatever never a good thing never a good
thing girl
never a good thing oh never a good thing
girl what never a good so these are all
the orphanage I'm here for your tears I
hear orphan tears gives you superpowers
and that's why I'm here I know you kept
them secret I know you have them
somewhere I don't care about the dangers
I will have those tears so I can [ __ ]
rainbows oh you kept the tears in a box
ha ha I'll find it eventually now let's
get what I want and when I want my
orphan tears I get my my tears
is that offensive to other less founded
[ __ ]
okay my clothes villa near committing it
slower spinning but oops
still got a sore leg what don't leave me
alone all right we got the tears we got
the key um I think it's about time to
get the [ __ ] out of here
what Oh God
shut up you can't tell me what to do
[ __ ] stupid punk ass nugget alright so
we got our tears we got the key um time
to get out of here huh huh aha
hey nice tits girl you work it mm-hmm Oh
maybe in here maybe there hey hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey oh we
can't go down there [ __ ] I don't
understand this [ __ ] all right what are
we got fabrics mannequins ah dolls huh
uh-huh no those are those are not right
don't what what what what does that mean
which colic don't touch me
whoa what the [ __ ] what what what what
what what what nope nope okay haha you
may think I was gonna stay in this place
nope I just came here to find some
ladies
they might okay there might be a little
okay it may appear it may may seem like
we're completely [ __ ] and I think
you're wrong I think we're fine
I think there's plenty of places to hide
and I think he's not gonna find this
single song
singasong cool I gotta go I gotta go I
gotta go I gotta go I gotta go all right
that's about all the time for today I
hope you guys enjoyed watching it like
to be dead let me know if you want more
to see more of this hits the sky combo
today I'll see you next weekend oh thank
you what just happened